[Music]
Alberta's out of control wildfires on
this Friday night we slept in their
vehicles the volatile conditions the
people forced from their homes and the
strangers lending a helping hand fresh
questions for the Prime Minister about
claims of Chinese interference the
conflicting answers criticism and lack
of clarity inching towards the end of
the pandemic the World Health
organization's latest declaration about
covet
and here in London we are hours away
from the king's coronation
the enthusiasm
a young Ontario man's opportunity of a
lifetime it's out of this world plus
Camilla's long journey from mistress to
Queen
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from London
good evening and thanks for joining us
on the eve of a first coronation of a
British monarch in 70 years we are here
overlooking Westminster Abbey their
Majesty's King Charles and his wife
Camilla the queen consort will both be
crowned and those who can't wait to see
it all got a royal surprise today
thank you
the king arrived to thank well-wishers
who were already lined up outside
Buckingham Palace
in about 30 minutes shaking hands
he's got very nice soft hands very nice
soft hands The Prince and Princess of
Wales showed up too their children will
play a role in the coronation and Kate
told one person they're excited but a
bit nervous every family has got the
Watts and all and we just love them it's
absolutely one of the most unbelievable
experiences of my life it was a busy day
earlier the king and queen consort
hosted a lunch for leaders of the
Commonwealth who have arrived for the
coronation
tonight a more formal reception at
Buckingham Palace for world leaders
including the first ladies of the United
States and Ukraine
we're going to come back to the
coronation a little later on but we want
to get to a developing story in Alberta
tonight dozens of wildfires fueled by
unusually hot temperatures and high
winds are raging about 13 000 people
have been forced from their homes and
Alberta needs help firefighters from
Ontario and Quebec are on their way it's
early May and already more than 80
active wildfires are burning in Alberta
nearly two dozen are out of control one
of them is in the Indigenous community
of Fox Lake and More Than 3 500 people
there have had to flee nitu garcha is in
high level Alberta tonight where many
evacuees have been sent yeah Donna this
sports complex behind me has been
converted into an evacuation Center
where hundreds of people mostly young
families are staying and many of the
resources inside are donations and it's
far from being the first time high level
has stepped up this way
forced out by these Flames thousands of
residents in the community of Fox Lake
now fearing for their future when
they'll return and what they'll return
to
the wind's picked up and they were 40
kilometer hour plus winds and move the
fire in that's when we started losing
homes and stuff local officials say the
fire has consumed the police station
main General Store and multiple homes
evacuees are in hotels
and reception centers in nearby
communities like this one in high level
I can't even imagine what their feeling
and I brought donations for the families
all the communities around here pulled
together when one Community heard say
who everyone comes together only
accessible by barge is considered the
most isolated community in Little Red
River Cree Nation several of the more
than 3 500 evacuees had never left the
community a lot of them are still under
healing Journey
and they're still learning to accept and
go forward local officials say this is
the 12th evacuation too high level since
2003 renewing their calls to Federal and
provincial governments for a dedicated
evacuation Center because we are so far
away from the bigger centers it's harder
for us to get the supplies needed and
the service area is so large like we're
a smaller Community but we're servicing
the whole area all around us
Crews from high level and Slave Lake are
supporting the effort to protect the
community from this out of control
Wildfire but intense winds have been one
of the biggest issues in the fire fight
now officials say while the Flames came
close the barge to the community is
still usable Little Red River Cree
Nation says the evacuation was supported
by private boats and some residents had
to be airlifted out but they say some
people are still missing and that the
chief has spent much of the day inside
the community trying to find and get the
last few people out Donna
all right in high level Alberta thank
you
there are wildfires in Saskatchewan too
near the musuman and Salto First Nations
fires are burned across at least 3 900
hectares of land another fire has led to
evacuation orders for hundreds of people
in the Clearwater River Dene nation and
La loche there are 14 active wildfires
in Saskatchewan right now
BC has more than 50 wildfires right now
plus flooding and mudslides in some
areas leading to evacuation orders and
highway closures and more heavy rain is
falling in the flood zones
there's still a state of emergency in
Cache Creek where a house has been
destroyed and people in 21 other homes
have been told to leave flood watches
and warnings are in place across species
Southern and Central interior and people
are doing what they can to try to hold
back the water
calls are growing for the federal
government to take action over reports a
Chinese Diplomat in Toronto was involved
in an alleged plot to intimidate
conservative MP Michael Chong and his
family today the Chinese government
called those allegations a political
stunt and raised its concerns with
Canada's ambassador to China about
reports Canada could expel the Diplomat
involved prime minister Justin Trudeau
continues to insist he did not know
about the threats until this week
Mackenzie gray reports
hello hey good to see you he tried to
focus on the liberal convention but the
Prime Minister was dogged Again by
Chinese interference that information
never made it up
to the political level in my office to
me or even to the minister of Public
Safety at the time Justin Trudeau
referencing a 2021 thesis report
outlining threats from the Chinese
government against conservative MP
Michael Chong and his family information
Trudeau previously said he first learned
about when it was reported in the Globe
and Mail was it ever briefed up out of
cesus it was not cesus made the
determination that it wasn't something
that needed to be raised to a higher
level but that explanation wasn't true
the prime minister's National Security
adviser contradicted him yesterday
telling trong thesis did share the
report with the privy Council Trudeau
wouldn't say who gave him the bad info I
shared the best information I had at the
time on Wednesday both to Mr Chong and
to Canadians but it turns out that
information was incorrect so who told
you the report never left ceases okay
um I get briefings regularly from
various sources I'm not going to go into
details on that and it's not even clear
who in the privy Council Office received
the report the Prime Minister had three
National Security advisors in 2021 but
only Vincent Rigby responded to
questions from global news saying he
left the job before the briefing was
written neither David Morrison nor Mike
McDonald both of whom are currently
high-level civil servants responded to
our questions it's clear that the
government doesn't treat these threats
seriously in an interview airing Sunday
on the west block Michael Chong says the
Prime Minister didn't want to know about
the report he's been prime minister for
almost eight years I think this might be
excusable eight months into a new
government but there's no excuse for
this eight years in the opposition has
called for the expulsion of the Chinese
Diplomat involved in the Chong story but
the Prime Minister wouldn't commit to
that Donna saying he's weighing the
potential impacts of kicking him out
all right Mackenzie gray and Ottawa
thanks well now back to the coronation
here in London excitement is building
Crystal gemancing it was with me crystal
so many people have a real connection to
the king and you met one Canadian who's
really excited to be here he absolutely
is his name is Jay Patel and he's a part
of a group of Youth ambassadors for the
prince's trust and in just a few hours
he'll watch History unfold up close
as people flock to the mall at times
battling the elements longing to be a
part of History one young Canadian holds
a golden ticket it's out of this world
despite being in London Jay Patel
doesn't entirely believe he's the
Canadian youth Ambassador for the
prince's trust and will be attending the
coronation they told me that you'll be
like one of the two thousand who will be
inside the Westminister Abby and I'm
like
one of the 2000. that now that sounds
really cool Patel turned to the prince's
trust in 2021 after moving to Canada to
attend school he was alone in a strange
country seized by a pandemic and needing
a job today he works as a cook at the CN
tower his majesty like
it's his charity who helped me out so
I'm always grateful and thankful to him
that he is doing this charity work
the prince's trust operates in 20
countries offering young people free
courses to build employment skills the
charity goes back to 1976 when then
Prince Charles used his Naval severance
pay to fund the initiative if you look
at the polls the king isn't very popular
with the younger generation but he does
have a long history of supporting youth
Patel is clearly a fan and his family
back in India is proud of all of his
hard work although he says his dad did
ask if he's sure his invite to the king
and queen concerts coronation is real
it's been like a hard journey but it has
it's not an end but I got like a
beautiful moment right now that I'm
gonna enjoy and someday it will be like
a really successful story for me
Patel says he is unsure how he will
respond on the day but Donahue has
prepared a bit of a pep talk for himself
he said he was going to tell himself to
be cool and just breathe all right I
love how his dad thought he had a fake
ticket Crystal commencing thanks
a war of words in the battle for back
moods coming up why a Russian mercenary
leader is threatening to pull out his
troops
this is a giant replica of Saint
Edward's crowd the one Charles will be
crowned with this one weighs 300
kilograms and is nearly five meters tall
we're back from London in a moment
it was with us for so long it felt like
it would never end well today the World
Health Organization declared covid-19 is
no longer a global Health Emergency
though it does warn the virus remains a
public health threat
the worst thing any country could do now
is to use this news as a reason to let
down its God
to dismantle the systems it has built
or to send the message to its people
that covid-19 is nothing to worry about
possible to know exact numbers because
few people are testing anymore but the
who estimates there have been more than
765 million confirmed cases of covid-19
around the world and that nearly 7
million people have died from it in
Canada there have been over 52 000
deaths
in Ukraine the leader of Russia's Wagner
paramilitary group is threatening to
pull his troops from bakmut because of
ammunition shortages and he posted a
graphic and expletive video criticizing
the Russian defense minister
foreign
bodies of dead Fighters evgeny progosian
said tens of thousands have been killed
he blamed Russia's defense Ministry
claiming ammunition supplies have been
cut frigosian says Wagner will lead back
moot by May 10th the unit's forces are
key to Russia's offensive in the region
Serbia has been shaken by another mass
shooting eight people were killed 14
others wounded when a gunman went on a
shooting rampage in two Villages south
of the Capitol the suspect wearing a
t-shirt with a Neo-Nazi slogan has been
arrested Serbia's president called it a
terrorist attack and he introduced gun
tough new gun control measures the
country is still reeling after a 13 year
old boy shot and killed eight students
and a security guard at a school on
Wednesday
[Applause]
triumphant image transformation ahead
Camilla's path to becoming Queen
this is Buckingham Palace where King
Charles was born 74 years ago were back
from London in a moment
[Music]
the woman at King Charles's side for the
coronation is Camilla Parker Bowles his
longtime love her Public Image has
undergone quite a transformation
the two had a decades-long affair while
they were both married to other people
and to some that made Camilla a villain
fast forward a few decades and she's
Queen
long before the fairy tale wedding of
Charles and Diana in 1981 there was
Charles and Camilla they first met in
1970. their bond never broke even when
they were married to other people
monarchy and monogamy rarely go hand in
hand I think that probably uh Camilla
has completed
uh her journey from from being you know
one of the most vilified women in this
country to be not one of the most
popular but being amongst a certain lot
of people very popular indeed that
Journey from mistress to Queen has been
agonizing in the early 90s when Charles
and Diana's marriage was faltering his
decades-long affair was revealed in a
recording of an intercepted explicit
bedtime phone call with Camilla the
tabloids dubbed it Camilla gate I'm sure
they were hideously embarrassed but I
think when people are in love
they say oh silly sorts of silly things
to each other
and but it's nobody's business I feel
that readers are big enough adult enough
and deserve to know the facts so we
published the transcript and they can
make their own minds up for Charles it
was humiliating proof of his affair and
brought into question his suitability is
air for Camilla it made her an outcast
the queen wouldn't go anywhere where she
knew she was and Prince Philip was
absolutely not interested in her Charles
never seemed to cut ties with Camilla
and that first interview he and Diana
did after their engagement was telling
I'm amazed that she's been brave enough
to take me on and I suppose in love
Diana later said she felt traumatized
after the interview
and that was just the beginning the
wedding went ahead and there among the
guests was Camilla she even befriended
Diana in the early days of the marriage
before Diana famously said in an
interview there were three of us in the
marriage so it was a bit crowded in his
book Prince Harry says he and his
brother William
urged their father not to marry Camilla
that he feared she'd be a wicked
stepmother and that she was a villain
and dangerous because he claims she
leaked stories to the press to bolster
Her Image I think she's brave because
she manages somehow to cope with people
saying awful things about her whether it
was Diana saying she was a Rottweiler
whether it's Prince Harry saying she's a
villain
after Diana's tragic death Camilla did
keep a low profile until this moment in
it was their first public appearance as
a couple photographers tipped off in
advance used so many flashes the British
epilepsy Association
urged broadcasters to stop airing it
they made every front page slowly
winning over the Tabloid press that it
almost destroyed Camilla it took longer
to win over the queen after a private
ceremony in 2005 when they were married
Charles's boys were there but not his
mother though she did host the reception
an enormous campaign a PR campaign has
been launched to to rehabilitate her and
to make her acceptable to the public and
it's been very effective six months
before she died the queen said it was
her special wish that Camilla become
Queen consort and Camilla has quietly
carried on she's Patron to many
Charities with a special interest in
domestic violence she worked very hard
plus and it's a very big plus she had
made Charles extremely happy very
relaxed they have so much in common you
know they loved they had the same sense
of humor they would Roar with laughter
at the same thing they're Perfectly
Imperfect love affair enduring it all
now as king and queen
[Music]
next Royal biographer Robert Hardman on
what to expect at the coronation
tomorrow
[Music]
welcome back to London no one outside
the royal family can truly understand
what it means to be a monarch Royal
biographers get a closer Glimpse than
the rest of us and earlier I spoke with
Robert Hardman he's a journalist and
author of queen of our times who's now
working on a book about King Charles
you know King Charles has prepared his
whole life for this role of course do
you think that makes it easier or more
difficult for him to own it I think it
makes it easier I mean he didn't really
like discussing it when his mother was
alive so it left to the rest of us
speculating what sort of a king is he
going to be with all ours and we never
got an answer because he felt it was
wrong to talk about these things while
his mother was Queen he is a
traditionalist and yet we've been told
that this coronation ceremony will be
different will be more modern what are
you expecting to see I'm expecting to
see some very ancient touches I mean the
the idea of anointing goes back to the
Old Testament of course some people will
say well how can I crowns and receptors
and fairy tale carriages have any place
in the 21st century Society but it does
because if you want a monarchy that's
what it comes with you go back to 1953
it was largely elderly war heroes and
Aristocrats
um very much white very male that was
that was the establishment of 53. this
is going to see a huge cross-section not
just a British life but a commonwealth
life you know very prominent Canadian
elements to it uh it it it's gonna it's
gonna feel younger but we won't see the
anointing
yeah what we will see we didn't see last
time we saw most of it last time but we
didn't see the only thing and we didn't
see Holy Communion the queen thought
that was a very personal and private
moment this time we will see both the
king and queen take communion and we
will also see the the queen being
anointed and the anointing it's a sort
of it's a dab the queen is being
anointed as well she is being anointed a
sort of a lesser an anointing compared
to the king he gets hands chest and head
in her case it's a sort of dab on on the
head but she will still be anointed and
that will be seen on on camera you know
for many people Queen Elizabeth was the
monarchy can Charles fill her shoes well
it's of course it's an incredibly tough
act to follow and we know he's
passionate about the environment we know
he's passionate about
architecture these sort of things
because he's spoken out about it in a
way that the queen didn't do and he
obviously has to be more careful about
how he pronounces things now but he's
not going to stop taking an active
interest in in things like the
environment he's just going to have to
do it a different way there is a more
vocal Republican movement in this
country now than there has been in the
past
do you have a sense of what it will be
like on Saturday how many people will
turn up how interested
obviously people who protest are more
vocal than people who are content I was
in Liverpool the other day and there was
a protest there and they were very much
a sort of small part of the crowd but
nonetheless uh you know they they they
they they Charmed
um and and uh not my king not my king
that's what they had a chance they've
got that's their slogan and they've sort
of they're certainly more active now
than than there was ever the case under
under the Queen's Reign because I think
they you know see this is their their
chance their opportunity you can't you
can't sort of approach it like a sort of
a a talent show or an election you can't
go sort of touting for votes or support
you've just gotta you've got to do what
your role is and hope that people
appreciate that that it brings some
benefit of course it's irrational I mean
if you were starting a new country
tomorrow you simply wouldn't suddenly
say I know we must put one family in
charge and put their faces on the coins
and banknotes and uh yeah I'm just sort
of leave them there and keep them there
in perpetuity I mean you wouldn't um but
but it's a system I mean there are so
many things in life that aren't rational
but you know we we're very fond of them
try Banning Christmas
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Donna Friesen tomorrow is the
big day our live coverage of the
coronation starts at 5 a.m Eastern 2 A.M
Pacific I'll be right here overlooking
Westminster praying it doesn't rain you
can watch it on global and on all our
streaming platforms it starts early so
get your hot cup of tea ready for now
bye bye from London
[Music]
thank you